[Music]
this is key point eight hours before the
midterm presentation he is happy she's a
wedding with her friends I thought to
celebrate with her friends be like Kate
this is Kate 12 hours before the midterm
presentation he is not happy she is
suffering from the lingering effects of
celebrating with her friends this is
Kate four hours and one minute before
the midterm presentation kate is happy
again do you like Kate unfortunately
this is Kate exactly four hours before
the midterm presentation when she
realizes that she has that same midterm
presentation in four hours don't be like
Kate fortunately for you all we're gonna
walk you through what to do if you find
yourself in a similar position as Kate
which is you have a limited amount of
time to prepare for a big presentation
and it start us off let me just gonna
walk us through what to do an hour one
four hours left until the presentation
thank you will
so it's game time and the clock is
ticking and if you like most of us
you're probably feeling anxious so the
first order of business is to make sure
we change your status from being anxious
to being in a state of flow now by show
of hands how many people know here what
is the flow state of mind awesome for
those who don't know it is a state of
mind that is fully immersive and helps
you focus at the job at your hand how do
you get from a state of mind a lot of
people also refer to it as a state of
being in the zone so today I'm going to
share a technique with you that will
allow you to get in the zone in less
than five minutes and it's called box
breathing it's a technique the
it's used by US Marines to go into a
state of focus feel calm and activate
the critical thinking and this is how it
works
you basically breathe in hold breathe
out and hold again and you do each of
these steps for seconds each let's try
it together breathe in hold breathe out
and hold again awesome so now that
you're in this ninja mode let me walk
you through the three steps of building
your presentation number one always
always start with your name and don't
just think about your aim write it down
it's gonna save you a ton of time in the
future number two pick your three key
takeaways research shows that people
only retain 20% of the information that
you share with them so you want to make
sure that you're absolutely clear about
your takeaways and number three create a
storyboard to limit the scope of your
presentation you don't have enough time
so you want to make sure you don't rely
on research but what you know already
and number three and most important when
it comes to visuals less is more
use the ollege principle of kiss keep it
simple stupid
in summary limited content told more
confidently is better than a ton of
details that you're not comfortable with
so with that said we have three hours
left and I'm gonna pass it on to with to
walk you through the content so we just
heard about some initial steps you can
take to id8 on what you're gonna say but
equally important is I da da da da da
ting on how are you gonna make that
content come alive for the audience how
to make it memorable and there's three
things I would encourage you to focus on
which is a lot of things we've actually
learned about in this class the first
thing is you need to have a hook I want
to give you two examples suppose I
started the presentation by saying hello
my name is William Faulkner and I want
to tell you about a skydiving experience
I once had versus I was 1500 feet above
sea level my first drink had failed and
I was falling about 400 feet per second
needing a thousand feet for the chute to
open I mean I had about two seconds to
save my life clearly the second is much
more effective that shall we say
parachuting the audience make sure you
have a good hook the second is find a
good story now I'll admit that it's very
hard to ID eight stories when you're in
a time pressure situation and therefore
what we have found the best way to have
a good story and a time constraint is
actually have a story bank before you
actually reach that time constraint and
I can speak for personal experience a
good way to have that story Bank is to
think about the people places of things
in your life that have created the
person you are today a great example is
applying Stanford Business School we had
to think about what matters to us most
and why
and is from that ideation process that I
can pull from my head right now three or
four personal stories to join get a
emotional connection with you the
audience regardless of the topic I can
change the story to meet the topic so
the second thing that you need to be
able to realize is that you need a story
bank that you can pull from at any point
in your life to deliver to an audience
on any topic the second thing you think
about is audience engagement and that's
really dependent on what kind of
audience are you speaking to for an
intimate class setting like this
audience engagement could be more than
just raising your hand it could actually
be following up with people if Janie
raises his hand in response to a
question I can call on him to actually
both live and tell me what
why he raised his hand I can even get
movement people moving to one side of
the room or the other for a bigger
audience obviously that's gonna be more
challenging and so maybe you can just
rely on things like raising your hand so
the three things I would focus on in the
third hour creating a hook
finding a story and figuring out how
you're gonna get your audience now that
we have two hours left
Oak Hill is going to talk about how you
should think about content now the good
news is that if you've been following
diligently along you've already avoided
the number one pitfall that people make
when they're designing slides under time
pressure and that is getting stuck in
design limbo we have all been there
before you are working and reworking
your slides over and over again you're
stuck in your head trying to figure out
exactly what you want to say meanwhile
the minutes are flying by and you're
getting nowhere fast the secret to
getting out of design limbo is to
reverse the process create your content
first design your slides last if you do
this you will go from spending 75% of
your time designing your slides to 25%
of your time designing your slides now
how'd I not follow this advice I
probably would have put together a slide
line what you see on the left now it's
not terrible I mean it even has a pie
chart we know how much JD loves pie
charts well the slide on the right is
better I used a photo slideshow
minimalist template to create the slide
on the right now you might be thinking
it's better because it's more
aesthetically pleasing it's simple and
those things are true but that's not the
reason it's better the reason it's
better is that while the slide on the
right took me 10 minutes to prepare the
slide on the Left took me ten seconds to
prepare and when you're in a time crunch
time is everything now 10 seconds is
awfully fast how did I design a slide in
10 seconds
the answer is I didn't use PowerPoint
PowerPoint not a great software for
designing beautiful slides quickly
instead I use a tool called haiku deck
and there are other tools as well like
beautiful
ái these are online pieces of software
that are great for minimalist templates
design when it comes to slides use one
of these templates and you'll save
yourself a ton of time to be apps okay
we have to we have one hour left we're
at the final part of our presentation
Kate's going to walk us through what to
do next now you have an hour left in
your presentation
why should you do yes you got a practice
now we will give you three important
tips to help you practice efficiently
first tip is to practice opening even if
you have ten minutes to prepare you
still have time to practice opening
there reason why I'm stressing the
importance of opening is because if you
can practice and perfect the first few
minutes of your presentation your stress
for the presentation will go down to
significant and the rest of the table
will fall into place much more easily so
now how to practice opening so our tip
is to remember first few sentences so
that those come out crisply and
confidently the second tip is to try to
memorize what to say not how to say it's
really important for you to have those
anchor points that will keep you on
track throughout the presentation more
specifically only memorize key phrases
that you want to stick to and key
interactions interaction points with the
audience such as asking a question at
the start of the top the final tip to
practice efficiently is to try three
rounds of practice focusing on content
vocal and visual remember when you
practice vocal and visual part
exaggerate everything top louder try
hand gesture use longer pauses
and tripower close this hole feel very
unnatural to you but to audience you
will look much more confident now it's
presentation time in four hours we
entered the right frame of mind we
picked out our content we prepared our
slides and we practiced in record time
if I had this tips if I had access to
the tips earlier I would have avoided a
lot of stress for my midterm
presentation it maybe earned a big hug
from those so in your individual
practicum if you find yourself having
just a few hours to prepare for
presentation we hope that you'll
incorporate some of our advice
[Music]